well you're right
thor love and thunder is the funniest
marvel movie to ever hit the silver
screen but it was also able to find a
way to fix the character of thor within
all the screaming goats naked gods and
jealous weapons but before we get into
it here is your official spoiler warning
we will be revealing spoilers for all of
thor love and thunder so if you don't
want to spoil the movie this isn't the
video for you quite yet taika waititi's
work on this film was absolutely
hilarious
and you can see his mark on almost every
scene in the movie to truly understand
how love and thunder fixed thor though
we'll first need to dive into the
character arcs he's had throughout the
mcu catalog before talking about the
hilarity that is thor love and thunder
[Music]
throughout the mcu thor has gone through
what i see as two major character arcs
the first arc spanned across thor thor
the dark world and thor ragnarok while
the second included avengers infinity
war avengers end game and now thor love
and thunder the other two movies he
appeared in the avengers and avengers
age of ultron gave him very little
screen time and next to no character
development so i'm mostly gonna just
ignore them in his first character arc
thor went from being a spoiled god
thinking only of himself and glory in
battle to someone who had lost
everything but still striving to be the
hero that his people needs i see his
first arc as one where a spoiled kid
sees true loss for the first time in his
life and it doesn't stop with just one
tragedy he loses his powers his brother
his best friends his mother his brother
again his home and his girlfriend these
movies tell a story of loss and
heartbreak with just one disaster after
another thor begins his arc as being
unworthy of even wielding mjolnir and
ends his arc understanding the asgard is
a people not a place thor's second
character arc begins with a hero who
continues to face loss and fails to save
his people falls into a depressive
vengeful state and redeems himself in
the end as a wholesome comedic hero
korg's intro to love and thunder says it
best he went from dad bod to god bod but
then went back to being a dad this
second arc tells a story of a god trying
to find his place in the universe
finally succeeding in love and thunder
he feels immense guilt for his inability
to defeat thanos before he snapped half
the universe away starts to redeem
himself and end game and fully realizes
his potential as a hero in the ark's
third act the main difference between
thor's first arc and his second is that
the first tells the story of a tragedy
while the second tells the story of a
comedy understandably both arcs have
major tragic events such as the loss of
asgard and even jane foster's death but
the main difference lies in each arc's
ending a tragedy always ends with a
disaster or heartbreak while a comedy
ends with a reunion or joy the first arc
was a tragedy because it ended with the
complete destruction of asgard and thor
ragnarok the second arc was a comedy
though because it ended with thor taking
on the mantle of fatherhood with gore's
daughter love giving meaning to the
movie's title thor love and thunder it's
even more meaningful too when you
realize that thor's new daughter figure
is actually played by chris hemsworth's
daughter in real life india rose
hemsworth while both sets of movies have
both tragic and comedic events they're
truly separated by who thor is at the
end of each arc you might be wondering
though how exactly did love and thunder
fix thor and how was he broken in the
first place
after the events of avengers infinity
war and endgame we were left with a sad
fat defeated thor with a big lebowski
mentality and no idea what his place was
in the world love and thunder brought
some life back into the character of
thor and all of the comedy we saw in
ragnarok although it's pretty cheesy and
campy thor finds himself and his place
in the universe as a dad fighting
alongside his new love love he
experiences more heartbreak with the
death of jane foster but he's able to
get closure and move on from their
relationship something he had never been
able to do before when all he got was a
note from her this movie fixed thor and
gave us a hilarious wholesome rom-com
with tons of little details that i loved
the opening guitar riff during the
marvel studios intro sequence was just
perfect along with all of the music in
the film the cinematography and use of
color in the movie was also great which
is to be expected from taika waititi
known for his striking color usage and
vibrant films i love the 80s vibes
present throughout the movie and all the
little details that could be easy to
miss on the first watch this movie was
chock full of hysterical moments like
frigga carrying a baby thor onto the
battlefield or thor riding stormbreaker
off a mountaintop like a witch on a
broom it was great to see matt damon and
chris hemsworth's brother luke hemsworth
return to play the stage actors we saw
in ragnarok alongside melissa mccarthy
as hella i loved seeing thor's new
tattoos of his brother loki across his
back as well as thor having some of
loki's hair braided into his own thor's
giant screaming goats tooth nasher and
tooth grinder were great to see too and
the film had some hilarious one-liners
such as when gore tells thor to call
stormbreaker and thor says only if you
call a dentist one of my favorite things
though was how the weapons in the movie
are treated like characters thor talks
to mjolnir and stormbreaker almost like
he's dating them and stormbreaker gets
jealous when thor seems interested in
the newly put together mjolnir it's just
hilarious to see thor interact with the
weapons like this when we've hardly
thought of them as characters of their
own before some of the funniest scenes
happened near the end of the film though
when we got to see little asgardian kids
given the power of thor momentarily
using stuffed rabbits as weapons and
also a little detail of korg making a
baby with someone named dwayne perhaps
nicknamed dwayne the rock something the
mid credits scene also got me super
excited because it showed us hercules
played by brett goldstein aka roy kent
from apple tv pluses ted lasso i can't
wait to see this rageful actor punch his
way into the mcu and get revenge for his
dad zeus
anyways leaven thunder was hilarious and
it had taika waititi's influence
throughout all of it the biggest thing
this movie had going for it though was
that it gave one of the best romance
stories we've ever seen in the mcu
before jumped only by wanda and vision
story and it just so happened to take
place in a rom-com
it was a bit stunning to see such a
comedic movie too especially right on
the heels of what i'd call a horror
movie in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness it'd be hard to
find two movies in the mcu that were
more different than these two and they
came out right after one another i don't
have too many negative things to say
about the movie other than pointing out
a couple of plot holes which could
probably be answered by thor just
forgetting they were an option the first
lies in thor being able to give other
people his powers like we saw him give
the asgardian children near the end of
the film if he could give other people
his powers why didn't he do so in the
battle against thanos also if thor was
able to reach infinity with stormbreaker
and have any wish granted why didn't he
think to make a visit and wish thanos
never got the infinity stones while
these may seem like pretty significant
plot holes i'm not too bothered by them
and still absolutely love the movie but
let me know what you think did love
thunder live up to the hype or did it
fall short from ragnarok drop your
thoughts in the comment section below
also check out the video on your screen
for some more of my content don't forget
to like and subscribe and thanks for
watching rocket riley
[Music]